l'événement en Oklahoma est incroyable
les foules sont incroyables ils
n'ont rien vu de tel Je regarde
les fausses nouvelles depuis des semaines maintenant et
tout est négatif
ne pars pas ne viens pas ne fais rien
aujourd'hui c'était comme  Je n'ai jamais rien vu de
tel Je n'ai jamais rien vu de
tel
vous êtes des guerriers merci nous avons eu de
très mauvaises personnes en dehors de muhammad
rasulallah' simplement pour désavouer le public
clarifier le vampirique Lamia Tulsa
Oklahoma kala pano Cisco le producteur
et ELISA Becker variable  mon spécial est
la política américaine Allah Shah je
danserai autour d'un bâton de ninja une béchamel va
très
compliments veux pitié Michaela graha
au dîner d'Allah, la douleur peut
analyser nourrir ma douleur toute la
politique de massage du torse comme avec elle Gandhi l'a
dit au  boulier IRM film sur aviaire
sur la recherche d'un million de personnes avoir une
réserve à La Plaza de menthe tourner le vertige
du soleil a donc camara Salim ala allah
sur une vague drame muesli exacta parier sur
même historique si unanimo  Passez généralement 60
personnes que vous recevez dans la zone suivante
avec le concepteur disponible, cela s'appelle
le travail des animaux. J'aime le nez et commence
ba-ba-boo le SS long Smart Office l'
aîné un charpentier salue l'exemple d'une bombe
si stupide tromperie Ellaria dissout le
virus Avakian avec les spectacles  c'est venu
sur Zeek conférer en avoir un, ils sont hautement la
plupart des autres baisers virtuels
activiste concept pacifiste sur la
politique océanique c'est important qu'une personne
soit Avex sur cet entraîneur est e15
immergé pour holla normal l'utiliser comme moi en
fait comme de  ce n'est jamais sur pradelio
l'accès à ses fosses d'air douces dans
la cour d'école un noir fané sur son
test éclairé était-ce comme moi comme le bas de Tino
il a fait ce test évalué pour
masquer sélectivement sur Flippa je veux sur Ricky ugh
Marty
alabanza QB  parmi la sensibilité qui fait
rebondir les affaires, Nivola fait un
plat moins sucré à Miami montre à travers la nourriture là-bas
calico pang le prix des développeurs de terme pour
Palmer en tant que pop en tant que bijoutier dans un
musée pour personne paralysée sur le re  produire
sur les organes comité de campagne SEO testy
positivo oka anniversaire nacré a fait un
million
Evangeline par cercle de bureau Solaris un
groupe esquivant la clé de hachage t CB une
noix de santa sur le suppresseur T
avare confirmer la porta de la ville probablement
le premier sur l'Oklahoma respecte
le commentaire sur l'offre de Policastro  Angela
Foster Donald Trump arrive,
cela s'appelle à propos de votre
Valdivia Flaminia bonjour Chris de le
dispersé à immersif pourriez-vous
autoriser une visite à propos de Noël d'Impala afin
de diffuser actuellement la co2 premium
fondatrice à holla le lobbying normal
sumo est la limite  ouais et
mardi islamique avec une parabole Jean votre publication
actuellement vous groupe de systèmes d'homme idiot de
vies noires comptez vous avez un
festival de commande de mise à mort voulait un extérieur de chameau en
zigzag un bloc aime un
panneau circulaire de sélectivité relique a un Donald
Trump de salade de piment supplémentaire
pouvons-nous  venir empathie sympathie paupières
4-11 Birsa Munda a dit de s'en tenir à l'
hémorragie relative de la  immatriculé
pour attirer Tite personnellement les panélistes sur - la
générosité de Joe Biden donc - 11 doodoos secrets
pointent le chat des marais c'est-à-dire
si vous passez - donc - votre propre application amadou de
taille moyenne peut venir échantillon de Donald Trump
qui a dit merci mec la vodka Joe
Biden Pandavas Michael Vick  un Joe Biden
un parc
cogner voir conseiller un point critique
monsieur donc l'école un visage qui en manque
sera près d'Allah comme maman dans les vallées
que Stickley expédie qui est-ce car vous avez besoin de
la voiture
tout-puissant excès et sur même le
bataillon pallidus un bucatini dans le  crapper comme
des insectes illogique sur eh bien ouais laisse
sur cette poche un masque séparé sur moi avant que
le masque des médias ne glisse dessus pour
moi il y a une leçon d'échelles je m'en fous
tu vas être papa cette fantaisie
essencial assez dormir super collant -
Mexicains à valider sur Jacob
au-dessus de votre professeur sympathie famille
people.com une puanteur vos décisions
réputation directeur d'impression animale
Markovic entreprise sur le déclaratif une
responsabilité multi-commande en t  il
partenaire poursuit FME sur l'
ovis Christa d'Emmy Mike Pence un mandat commun et la
discussion était prête réponse sur bande à
Estes Park a la Kosova
quatre-vingt-douze Zola sur une entreprise manque de
ce n'est jamais exactement
ouais pas de commentaire sur haka Bassam s'il vous plaît
deuxième Oh Giorgio a appelé un  le passager dit
John Bolton ouais s'il quitte constamment les mêmes
parties de la terre alors Olympus of Samadhi
malossi desert review result of Italy a
visité l'Allemagne sur une épopée Tonto Georgie
qui est une chanson sur les services publics
c'est sur des DVD exactement désolé sue dit que
vous présenterez un charme venir  dire 22 regarder
haletant tenir Leda me routine d'accord
pour ne pas voir une trompette canal uttanasana est
également devenu singe keiki avez-vous deviné
le seul bouddhiste particulièrement devenir si
émotif que je peux garder un pays excédentaire
pas comme c'est moi de l'hépatite
Kasich anciens tous  les nouvelles chansons peu
recherchées idée de soulagement
et pour parler de tunnel tourné c'est un
cadeau obtenir une carotte maladive et
conservée exactement pas mes commentaires qui
font hurler Pouchkine  ville de l'
entité de la dette nationale en tant que
capacité respectée ou conservatrice à frapper zéro kill
v8f Hema Ocala Maison Blanche un caissier
peut la distance d'un laissez-passer ou d'un thé
s'il vous plaît
ce n'était pas le moins élevé Chandler
tout à fait buku buku junkie mon père Araceli
olive sur le  propriétaire portefeuille final
plus rapide Géorgie Fidel olive une
marchandise le pivot crânien un
ennemi favorable des pommes de terre une campagne ce
convertisseur peut sur un clairon MacDonald certaines
ressources de l'œdème Wow